[Music]
[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here
youtube is great but the algorithm is
forgetful you can help this channel out
tremendously just by clicking the like
button
so youtube remembers to remind people
when my videos come out
burning beyond you atreides you shall
have no souls
nor spirits nor bodies nor shades
nor magic nor bones nor hair nor
utterances nor words
you shall have no grave nor house nor
hole
nor tomb
a curse is an invocation a prayer that
calls for harm to fall upon another
we all pretty much know what curses are
but today i want to talk about curses
thematically
in the context of frank herbert's dune
of course
now before we get into the meat of this
we have to discuss a small bit of greek
mythology
specifically one particular dynasty
described in pseudo-greek history
the house of atreus according to greek
mythology
king atreyus once ruled over the great
city of my city
in the midst my city was originally
founded by perseus
who was the son of the god zeus and dyna
a princess of the city argos real world
vicini
was once the center of greek society and
possessed a military stronghold
which dominated much of southern greece
atreus's descendants
were referred to as a traia day they
were known collectively
as the house of atreus greek mythology
presents the histories of several great
dynasties
and the history of house atreus is a
long and bloody one
for they were a cursed family the curse
began when king tantalis
grandfather of a trace offended the gods
as a result he was condemned to torment
beneath the earth
and a generational curse was set upon
his family the house of atreus was
infested with betrayals
corruption and even familiside
it all went on and on until one
descendant
orestes was able to break the unending
bloody cycle
by accepting his fate and the punishment
for his crimes
and the crimes of his house by
submitting himself to the furies
the greek female deities of vengeance
who live beneath the earth
where they tormented the guilty only
this broke the curse of the house of
atreus
it is no secret that frank herbert took
some degree of influence from greek
mythology
with his creation of house atreides in
doom
house atreides like the house of atrese
is continually plagued with misery and
tragedy
nearly all members of house atreides
that we encounter in the books
are met with tragic ends duke lato
like his father died before his time
after being captured by his enemy the
baron harkonnen
his children paul and elia both lived
tormented lives
and suffered tragic ends paul's first
son lato is killed as an infant
paul's second son late to the second
lives a tormented existence
imprisoned in a non-human vessel a body
which can never feel the touch of
another human
even distant atreides descendants are
not free from the curse
the descendants of ganema paul's
daughter all live
uneasy existences maneo dies in the
service of the god emperor
darwi o'drade and lucilla both distant
descendants of paul atreides
meet tragic ends whilst trying to ensure
the survival of the mini jesuit
sisterhood
the same for miles teg and a trey's
descendant said to strikingly resemble
the duke lato
he dies on arrakis soon after unlocking
new abilities hidden away within the
atreides genetic code
so if you take a step back and look at
the story as a whole
it definitely seems like frank herbert
took more than
simply just the name atreides from greek
mythology
it seems that like the house of atreus
house atreides is also cursed
at least they are cursed thematically
curses may or may not
exist in the dune universe but
everything that plays out in the story
plays out as if the great house is in
fact afflicted
there are literal curses uttered against
house atreides in the series also
though as i said it's not obvious that
frank herbert is denoting any actual
otherworldly power to them it's more
likely that he is merely using them as
thematic expressions decades after the
defeat of the patasha emperor shadon
carino iv
after paul latreidi's his marriage to
princess ireland
after the birth of the pre-born twins
lato angonema
aaliyah atreides sister of paul atreides
rules the human imperium
with an iron fist and now even mini
frimen held ill will towards the
atreides
countless freemen had died since paul's
ascension to the throne
they had offered themselves up in
service of muadeeb's war
among the maquis of the inner desert the
name atreides was spat upon
these fremen rebels hated the atreides
so that they visited upon the atreides a
terrible and ancient friman curse
burning beyond you a tradies
you shall have no souls nor spirits nor
bodies nor shades nor magic nor
bones nor hair nor utterances nor words
you shall have no grave nor house nor
hole nor tomb
you shall have no garden nor tree nor
bush
you shall have no water no bread nor
light nor fire
you shall have no children nor family
nor heirs nor tribe
you shall have no head nor arms nor legs
nor gate nor seed you have no seeds on
any planet
your souls shall not be permitted to
come up from the depths and they shall
never be among those permitted to live
upon the earth on no day shall you
behold shah
lude but you shall be bound and
feathered
in the nether-most abomination and your
soul shall
never enter into the glorious light
forever and ever
it was said that those frimen the
monkeys of the inner desert
consigned all the atreides to what they
call the left hand of the damned
the woman's son which is full of burning
paul atreides in the book children of
doom also speaks of a curse that has
been set upon house atreides
he seems to believe that it is this
curse that has caused the tragedy of his
life
and of all the atreides lives in the
deep desert when his son later ii
confirms that paul's sister
aaliyah is in fact possessed by an
ancient ancestral ego memory
as the result of her not being able to
withstand the influence of her inner
lives
paul admits to this i am not abomination
though i might have been later said i
saw how it goes with aliyah
a demon lives in her father ghani and i
know that demon
it is the baron your grandfather paul
buried his face and his hands
his shoulder shook for a moment then he
lowered his hands and his mouth was set
in a harsh line
there is a curse upon our house i pray
that you would throw that ring in the
sand
that you deny me and run away to make
another life
paul wanted lato to free himself from
the burden of ruling house atreides
and thus the universe he had hoped by
doing so
later could break the family's curse but
lato could not reject his responsibility
as paul had done
considering all of this it seems obvious
that frank herbert was likely thinking
about house atreus
when he was crafting the destiny of
house atreides
things were never meant to go well for
them and that is true from the beginning
of the story
until the end of it ultimately the dune
saga is a tragic series
the protagonists suffer greatly in an
unforgiving and deadly universe
again here i'm discussing the curse of
house atreides
in terms of how the story plays out
thematically for them
i'm not saying that there is an actual
supernatural curse against them
although i suppose it's up to each
reader to decide for themselves
frank herbert is not alone in weaving
real world mythological elements into
science fiction this is something that
science fiction author dan simmons also
does very well in his hyperion series
which i have covered in several videos
and i tend to do more of
well that's all i got for today guys
make sure you like and subscribe
for more quinn's ideas and also follow
me on twitter
[Music]
hi guys it's quinn again i just realized
that i haven't taken the time to
officially acknowledge that not too long
ago on this channel
i hit 300 000 subscribers and i just
wanted to say thank you to everyone that
is subscribed
thanks to everyone that watches my
videos it means the world to me
um i hope that you guys will continue
watching my content i will continue
producing
uh the best content that i know how to
make
i love the science fiction genre so much
i love the doom saga so much
and i just really appreciate all the
support from you guys thank you so much
for liking my videos i appreciate all
you guys comments
and thank you guys so much for being
here with me peace out
foreign